great
uh so nieve what is your personal
history with
video nasties were they a part of your
life like growing up were you
like did you watch those kind of films i
was not familiar with the whole video
last year until
i until the audition came around and
then i had to start researching it
fairly rapid
so my introduction in my education was
through through sensor and during this
research process what were some of the
films you watched
so prano sent me like a long list of
video nasties to check out so
the kind of the one the main ones was
let's get our best carry jessica to
death uh
texas chainsaw massacre the little dead
um oh my gosh there was so many
oh the one that really stood out and
frightened the crap out of me
and it was cannibal holocaust
yes with like the real animal cruelty
and stuff yeah yes and um
when we were in the rehearsal process we
kind of took
that the turtle sacrifice scene and we
kind of use that as one of the main kind
of
reference points for what it is that
this some of the
content of which sensors are kind of
become desensitized to
um and so for enid that was
it was interesting researching because
this was a character who was not
actually affected by it
she she views it through a completely
different lens
i would be like this the whole time
opposite of enos uh and during this
research process
um did you speak to any film sensors
what was something surprised you learned
about what that job entails
yes so prano i was in south africa at
the time shooting season one of
uh raised by wolves and uh prana put me
in touch
with um a a retired film sensor from the
bbfc
and so she was amazing because we skyped
and it was just it was more so
the it was more so just
learning about what the day entailed how
much content you're watching
a day but she said like so much of it
was just
how bad the quality was and just you
know it was like there was no way that
someone would
mistake this for actual intestines when
it was clearly just sausages
strung up and and then it was more so
just the content of which like you have
at
cannibal holocaust where she said like
there's there's no excuse
for animals to be you know to be killed
for the
for the purpose of entertainment and the
same goes with obviously
people and going through such like a
traumatic event like and i know that
we're talking about
um texas chainsaw massacre kind of came
into conversation i was talking to her
and just the actress
within that who was kind of subdued to
such such a horrific experience and
she was if when she was
actually die and just you know for the
director
you know that's just poor direction
make-believe and uh create create movies
it's not
we're not creating documentaries
that's true and you brought up this kind
of gulf of
you the actor maybe feeling horrified by
this stuff going on but the character
being very repressed and very
almost emotionless and i'm curious what
is that golf like
to play what is it like to play such a
kind of
repressed character
it's it's quite quite quite exhausting
for they like the early stuff where
she's kind of holding everything in
and because everything for enid is like
it's bubbling under the surface and
she's constantly just trying to keep
this lid on
leading her emotions she herself censors
um
her emotions to the to to others she's
very closed off and distant
and comes across quite cold so kind of
at the end of each take you just be like
oh so i finally take that deep breath
and i'm vote what that is that the
character was
deep deep down but then as the film
progresses and you got this
she kind of breaks through this
threshold and begins to kind of feel
everything
and that was for me was incredibly
cathartic
that makes a lot of sense and as she
breaks this threshold
you know without getting into spoiler
territory
reality starts to bend surrealism starts
to come in how did you track
or did it matter quote unquote what was
real versus what was maybe a
psychological manifestation what was
kind of the road map
you put for what this character was
going through um
for me it was always i always looked it
even though you know
studying the script and you know what it
is that prana was trying to depict
whether or not it is that
she is feeling it or not but for me i
always had to maintain that
what prana sees is is truth and she
is experiencing this and she has seen it
for what it is as opposed to
trying to play it on two different
levels because i think when you begin to
do that you begin to
um gesture or
you try to like throw the audience off
but if you're just playing at
the truth of what the character is
feeling and experiencing
it's up to them to decide what what it
is
that they think is actually going on and
so that for me is the most important
was that she was experiencing muscle in
all of these things but
um along the way begins to lose kind of
side of that it's interesting
the word gesture as it relates to
performance because when i watch these
kinds of low budget
video nasties i feel like you see a lot
of actor
gesturing or like being big and bold
with their emotions
in the moments when the film starts to
kind of ape that style a little more
explicitly did you feel your performance
style changing
or was it more of a we're sticking with
what we've
established beforehand that's a really
interesting question
um i think it's just because
once she like ian it feels like she's
beginning to put on a costume
it's almost like the years and the
amount of material that she would have
watched
as a film sensor of the video nasty and
those and those
those actors have kind of rubbed off on
her in some ways
and so it's almost like she adapts she's
beginning to adapt to that world
um but it's almost like she can't help
but feel that way or remote that way and
it's like she's
she's she's only she's only kind of
mimicking what she feels like is the
right thing to do
because this is someone who has not felt
this way she's
she has suppressed this feeling and so
for her it almost
when she begins to feel certain things
um
it feels like a an act
yeah um i did want to touch on you
brought it up a little bit ago i wanted
to touch on raised by wolves a little
bit
um and i'm just curious what if you can
talk about it is
exciting you or surprising you about
where season two is going
i can't i like it's rude reading the
scripts
was like it's almost like aaron
our writer has just opened up a whole
other door
and audiences you cannot guess where
this
where season two is going that's all i
want to say because it's such
it's so exciting and i don't want to
give anything away
and i don't want i just want it to be
as magical for audiences to experience
as it was for us to to read scripts for
the first time so
it's um you know it's the world of
ridley scott
so you know and it's very much living up
to that
i can't wait um that character on that
show
and enid both have a lot of
intrigue and secrecy with like their
identities
and quote unquote who they actually are
what do you find
interesting or satisfying about playing
characters with
complicated identities or even like
secrets about who they actually are
i was i was i was told by uh stephen
graham is like everyone's got a secret
all the time in their heads
and they never give it away even even
you right now there's
you've got something in your head a
secret that you're not going to tell
anyone
um but we don't know that and that's
what i think what makes it so
interesting
is that we don't always have the answers
and we never as you say
um showcase or gesture
what it is that we're feeling we're
always we're always we've always got
like
a couple of other things going on in our
head at any one given time it's not just
one thing
we're not single-minded were very
complex humans
that makes sense um there is one
character i saw you play recently that i
did feel a little bit
i know exactly who this person is and
that was dana in wrath of man
which i just thought was such a badass
character
um what did it feel like orienting
yourself to this kind of
more like grim macho guy ritchie world
what was exciting about working on that
movie it was like a pacing
to guys movies and there's also a pace
into his direction it's really quick
and fast and that for me like it's
always exciting to
to work with with different directors
and they like guy
has guy has his own
he's got his own world and he's got his
got his way of
of creating movies that it's
it's disease packs so much in and like i
remember just in one day we were
we covered so much we went from like
playing pooled by the end of the day we
were all
shooting guns it was just like it's
it was just so much happening in one day
and it's always really fun to just
to kind of keep the audience guessing
what you're going to do next and never
play the same card twice
definitely i mean you mentioned
different directors
bringing out different kind of levels of
excitement and vocabularies
this is prano's first feature film and
i'm curious what you
enjoyed about working with a first-time
future filmmaker
it's funny that because it just i didn't
feel like i was working with a
first-time feature filmmaker on this she
came she came to this project with
almost like 20 years of experience
um you know she'd been working on the
script for years
and her
her level of collaboration
i have not seen matched on anything else
that i've worked with she's
from from each department everyone
had their voice heard and that is so
important because
like everyone kind of brought their own
kind of blueprint to
what it is that they wanted to see
portrayed in their character from the
costumes to the makeup
to the art department to the
cinematography
it was like we were all you know singing
from the same hymn sheet
and so she has this amazing shorthand
with her gop annika summerson
and that for me i just took a way of
just seeing
just that openness and that
collaboration and we were shooting on
film and
with the amazing thing about film is
that you can actually hear the film
going you know rotating within within
the camera
and that's such a terrifying things and
actually because you know you've only
got like a certain set amount of time
from when when that film turns over to
when it
ends and because it's just burning money
because it's literally
you don't it's not like you know you
just keep on shooting but
having you know doing your first feature
film on film
i never felt under the pressure of going
okay i need to get this right
and there was no nobody was rushed on
set and we never went over
and it's just such a how you can make
films and everyone can be calm and happy
it's it's you know it's it was such a
beautiful
um you know beautiful atmosphere on set
and i think what i take from this is
just that
what we don't we don't need to try and
what we're you know we're making films
we're not
changing the world and and then just to
enjoy it and have fun
and to you know look after one another
and be kind because you know we're not
here for a long time
just you know make it a good time it's
interesting to hear you say
we're making films we're not changing
the world this is a film
that is very explicitly about
a person who thinks that films have the
power to change the world for the worst
and i'm curious what is your perspective
especially after working on this on
the relationship between film violence
and the horrors of the real world
if there is a relationship
yeah it's not all like life imitating
art you know i don't think it's like
that whole like
we watch something violent like just
does watching something
explicitly violent make someone violent
and
that's what i suppose enid's
relationship to this is is that she's
constantly trying to
censor the world of the bad things that
can happen to people
and and that i think that's where the
character
falls into this this whole because you
can't
just you know you have to be as truthful
in in filmmaking and for me it's why i
kind of got into acting is that i just
wanted to see
the correct representation of people
that i identified with
or if i didn't see see that being
represented on screen it's just
giving that person that voice
that makes a lot of sense thanks so much
for your time it's great chatting with
you
thanks greg